mono et michel darnell et je suis la
femme la plus riche d'amérique à quel
point je suis riche je voulais arriver
sur un phénix doré et je me suis offert
ce phénix de l'être je suis disponible
pour vous alors que je suis mère
célibataire je mérite d'être augmentée
tallard dont rita eu des rapports
sexuels
c'est bon pour toi vous êtes en état
d'arrestation pour délit d'initié n'est
pas la forte tête la sem wanda tarn
enterprises est en faillite ont gelé
tous vos comptes bancaires
claire trop - un autre avocat t'as plus
d'argent
tu peux être ok
même en ciel a nulle part où aller elle
a qu'à rester chez nous na li
incorporer un canapé il est vieux mais
il est conforté sa vague 4
je me suis pété le bassin michel sortait
de la salle de bain c'est mon dieu je
mets d'autobronzant patrow de champion
et des moisissures l'arrière de mes
cuisses et bien là et évitiez pas ça il
faut décoller que ce canapé et bouger à
chelles à une réunion avec les dents de
lyon 10,3 détient le record avec 189 et
rideaux noirs
la vache à quoi ça sert tout ça c'est
mon come back en affaires on va créer
l'emploi de produits et développer le
sens du commerce chez ses filles recrute
celles qui sont agressives
il nous faut des filles quand veulent
c'est qu'ils se battent christelle
direction trouve des filles qui ont des
prénoms de pierres précieuses
vous m'avez quoi alors mais là sur la
liste écoutez bien qu'est ce qu'on dit
quand une personne n'aurait pas les buts
et si tu dis non ne dis pas ça de suite
dit ça c'est le territoire des dents de
lyon
cette fournée à brûler ce pull beige
l'air de bien je lâche pas faire juste
avant mon rendez-vous touches pas tu me
fait douter de moi écoutons direct de
basse intensité michon pouvaient parler
ils diraient pitié que lui n'en sait pas
ce qu'il dirait peux-tu nous au petit
peu comme deux gouttes on le laisse moi
voir ça regarde on dirait que je suis
geppetto